[MUSIC PLAYING]
LARRY YANG: Good
afternoon, everyone.
Welcome to today's session on
subscriptions on Google Play.
I want to give a
special shout out
to all the people around
the world watching us
right now on the live stream.
Yeah.
Woo!
[APPLAUSE]
My name is Larry Yang.
I'm a product manager on the
Google Play billing platform.
Today, I'm joined by my fellow
product manager, Angela,
and our business
development lead, Niko.
Say hi, everyone.
NIKO SCHROER: Hi, everybody.
ANGELA YING: Hi.
LARRY YANG: All right,
let's kick things off
with a quick show of hands.
Who here is already running
a subscriptions business
on Google Play?
Wow, that's like
over half the room.
That's awesome.
All right, who here
is looking to get
started on running a
subscriptions business on Play?
All right, that's like
about a third of the room.
That's awesome.
Well, good news for all of you.
Today, we're going to
run through a whole bunch
of features and
capabilities that you
can use right now to start
a subscriptions business,
whether you already have
an existing business
and you're looking to
optimize your growth,
or if you're just looking
to get something started.
But before we jump in,
let's take a quick look
at why we're even all here
talking about subscriptions.
Subscriptions is one
of the fastest growing
businesses on mobile today,
and it's no surprise.
Users have been telling us
that they love subscriptions.
They love the value that
subscriptions provide
and they love the access
to continuous fresh content
that they get via a
subscription service.
And users have
demonstrated this love
by making subscriptions a
part of their daily lives.
In fact, 62% of paid
Android subscribers
use their subscription app at
least once every single day.
And because users
love subscriptions,
developers love them, too.
Let's watch a short
video highlighting
some of the great success
that you developers have
had on subscriptions
on Google Play.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
All right, that's
pretty cool, huh?
So this is a real testament
to all the great work
that you developers have done
on subscriptions on Google Play.
But together, we
can do so much more.
So today, we're going to
share three things with you.
First, we'll recap some of
the features we've rolled out
recently and share
some of the successes
that developers have seen
with those recent features.
Next, we're going to
announce a dozen new features
that you can put to
work right away to help
grow your business.
And finally, we'll give a
sneak peek at some of the ideas
that we have around the corner.
But more importantly,
tell you what
you can do today to
be ready for when
those features are available.
So Niko, why don't you come
on up and get us started.
Tell us about some of
the successes developers
are having today.
NIKO SCHROER: Thanks, Larry.
The past 12 months have
been truly exciting
for subscriptions
on Google Play.
We, as a team, have
worked hard to address
the biggest challenges you
are facing as developers.
For example, minimizing churn.
So quickly, want to
run through three
features we have seen successful
developers use to do just that.
Number one is real time
developer notifications.
Real time developer
notifications
give you immediate
notifications when
the subscriber state changes.
For example, a subscriber
renews or cancels.
Essentially, it changes the way
you operate your subscription
business on Google Play,
especially in regards
to minimizing subscriber churn.
Let me quote two of our top
developers on this feature.
Brain training app Elevate
says, real time developer
notifications have helped
them identify the exact moment
a user cancels.
So they can remind them of
the benefits of a subscription
and entice them to resubscribe.
And music streaming on
[INAUDIBLE] loves real time
developer notifications because
it lets them predict subscriber
churn--
real time, and quickly target
canceling users with win
back offers.
The bottom line
is, for developers
serious about retention, real
time developer notifications
have become a must.
Secondly, we
invested quite a bit
in helping you combat
involuntary churn because it's
just so painful.
You've spent all this time
building a great product
or service, then you convince
users to become subscribers
to your product,
just so they may
churn because, for example,
they forgot to update
their form of payment.
That's why we have seen such
great success with a grace
period, which allows us to
re-try to charge subscribers
whose payment has failed for
a defined period of time.
An account hold which
lets you put subscribers
in a suspended state, until they
update their form of payment.
As you can see here in
the example provided
by our partner,
Musixmatch, that's
notifying the user about
the payment that has failed.
Lastly, we offer really great
feedback on the Play Console
subscription reports we launched
at IO last year on this stage.
Actually, over there,
and how it provides
many ways to analyze
your business
and find optimization potential.
Developers have made it
the primary destination
for business
intelligence for anybody
working on subscriptions
in their company.
So to quickly summarize, our
most successful developers
show us how these features help
them build great subscription
services today.
So we recommend all of
you to check them out
if you're not already
using them, anyways.
OK, enough of features
you already know.
I want to welcome
Angela to tell you
all about the new
things we're announcing.
ANGELA YING: Thanks, Niko.
[APPLAUSE]
We've talked about how much
users love subscriptions.
We strongly believe that
by building a great user
experience, we're also building
a high quality subscriber base.
But we know that the
user experience is not
always perfect.
So just taking a quick straw
poll out there, how many of you
have hesitated to sign up
for a subscription service
because you thought it would
be too annoying to cancel
or it was just going to
be a hassle to remember?
I know I have, and I see a
bunch of you guys have, as well.
And this is what we found
in our user research.
Users told us that
while they can
derive a lot of value out
of their subscriptions
once they've signed
up, they also
feel like they'll be
trapped in the subscription
without the ability to cancel.
And since the
majority of our users
also have multiple
subscriptions to manage,
they're worried that
they'll lose track
of how much they're spending.
These fears create a
barrier for users signing up
for your subscription apps, and
we want to address that fear.
And so we're really excited to
announce that we're launching
a new subscription center.
This is a one stop
shop for users
to manage their
subscriptions in Google Play.
We've done a
complete UX overhaul
of our old subscriptions
page to make it easier
for users to get
more information
about their subscription,
easily fix their payment issues,
and do other actions, such as
restore their subscription.
But rather than
talk about it, let
me just show you how it works.
Niko has graciously volunteered
to be my demo person.
NIKO SCHROER: Yes.
ANGELA YING: Can I get two
forward on the slides, please?
OK, we're just going to do this.
NIKO SCHROER: Do you
want to go to the demo?
ANGELA YING: Yeah, so
let's go to demo A, yeah.
OK, so Niko, could you
open the Play Store
and open the Hamburger menu?
OK, so we're looking at
Vincent Verily's account,
and we can see that
subscriptions is now
on a very prominent position
on the Hamburger menu.
This is something new that
has already been launched.
So let's see what happens when
you go into subscriptions.
So Vincent doesn't actually
have any subscriptions,
but there's a new empty state
with a Get Started link.
So let's see what happens
when you tap Get Started.
When we tap Get Started,
we see that there
is a whole new selection of
different subscription apps
that the users can explore.
And keep in mind that this
is not the final version.
This is something that
our amazing merchandising
team is working on,
making a better experience
day after day.
So let's actually see
what the subscription
center looks like when the
user has some subscriptions.
Can you switch to
Wendy's account, please?
NIKO SCHROER: Yeah.
ANGELA YING: OK, so we can see
that Wendy actually has three
subscriptions in her account.
One of them has the
payment decline,
which needs to be addressed.
But in general, we can see that
she has all this information
about her
subscription, including
the SKU name, which is something
that we didn't have before.
And in order to go in and
manage a specific subscription,
we just have to tap somewhere.
So Niko, let's tap
on Pearl & Straw
to manage that subscription.
So let's say that Wendy
just got a new credit card,
and she wants to use
that for her subscription
and she wants to update
that payment method.
So Niko, let's tap Update
under primary payment method.
So now we can see all
of the payment methods
that Wendy has in her account.
So let's go ahead and switch
that to the new credit card.
So we're done now, right?
Well, we've actually
launched a cool new feature,
so you could either tap Got
It, and Wendy can go back
to enjoying her bubble
tea subscription,
or we can tap Add Backup to add
a backup payment method, which
is a payment method
that will charge in case
the primary fails.
And this is also a new feature
that we have already launched,
and is available today.
So let's go ahead and use that
old credit card as the backup.
Awesome.
And so now, we're all set.
So let's switch back
to the slides, please.
Sorry.
OK.
With the launch of the
subscription center,
we're also launching new deep
links specifically designed
for developers.
You can direct your
users to manage or fix
their subscriptions from your
app, over email, over web--
really, over any platform, and
it's super easy to implement.
All you really need is the
pack name and the SKU name
to construct the deep
link, and then you
can put that deep link
in a button or a link
from any of your properties.
So let's cut back to the
demo to see how this works.
So Niko, I need my yak fix.
Can you open the
Fabulous Yak app?
NIKO SCHROER: Sure.
ANGELA YING: Oh man.
I wanted to access that
premium article about yaks,
but all I see is a dead yak.
So I guess-- let's
manage payment methods
and see what happens.
OK, so I just followed
the deep link,
and now I'm in the
manage subscription
page for the Fabulous Yak app.
And I can see that there's
an action required,
so there's a problem
with my account
in that the awesome thing is
that there's also a CTA for me
to fix this problem.
So let's go ahead
and fix that problem.
So it looks like the old
credit card, which is actually
the credit card which we
wanted to update earlier,
has been declined.
So let's go ahead and
update that to the new one.
Awesome.
So now, it looks like the
subscription has been updated.
Why don't we check whether
we can access the Yak premium
subscription again.
Nice.
The payment's been
fixed, and we're back
to the premium experience.
And that yak is so happy, he's
just over the moon with joy.
Let's cut back to
the slides, please.
[APPLAUSE]
Finally, I'm very, very
excited to announce
that we'll be launching a
survey to users for when
they cancel this subscription.
This is a feature that many,
many of you have asked for,
and you can access the survey
answers through our server side
API today.
And eventually, you'll also
be able to see the answers
in console reporting.
So we're still rolling out
the user facing changes,
but because we've
already launched the API,
if you query it
today, you'll see
a small percentage
of the answers
that users have already input.
So let's get back to the
demo to see how this works.
So Niko, let's go to the Play
Store and to Wendy's account
again.
So Wendy is not only
a big fan of Yaks--
she also loves narwhals.
But she's gotten kind of
tired of the narwhal monthly
newsletter, so let's just cancel
that subscription for her.
So let's go into Narwhal,
and then it's really easy.
We just tap Cancel Subscription.
Now what we see
is a quick survey
for the user to give the
developer some feedback
as to why they're canceling.
And there are already a
few pre-written answers,
but Wendy has a
pretty specific reason
and can select Other
to type in that reason.
So Niko, she told you what
that reason was, right?
NIKO SCHROER: She did, indeed.
She said, there are
not enough narwhals.
ANGELA YING: I mean, I guess
they are an endangered species,
so that makes sense.
All right, let's finish
canceling that subscription.
Cool.
And the nice thing is even
if tomorrow, Wendy wakes up
and she's realized she's
made a huge mistake,
she can actually go back
and restore her subscription
in the subscription center.
So let's go ahead and
restore that subscription.
Awesome.
So now, Wendy can continue to
enjoy her narwhal subscription,
even next month.
And that's it for the demo.
So let's go back to
the presentation.
[APPLAUSE]
At Google, we've always believed
that if you focus on the user,
all else will follow.
Because of this new user first
experience to easily manage
subscriptions, users
will trust our store
and engage more with your apps.
With the subscription
center, we'll
also be able to deliver
more capabilities
to you, the developer.
The deep link and cancel
survey are just two examples
of these new abilities.
So let's go back to Larry
and Niko, who will tell you
about the other new
developer features
that we're coming out with.
LARRY YANG: Thanks, Angela.
NIKO SCHROER: Thank you, Angela.
Can we get a round of applause
for flawless demo execution?
[APPLAUSE]
So when I'm not busy
demoing things at IO-- so
to say in real life, I'm part
of the Google Play business
development team.
The Google Play business
development team,
on a daily basis, works directly
with subscription developers
of all kinds of backgrounds
around the world.
Naturally, we hear a lot
of feedback and ideas
for features, which we
then take to our PM teams,
such as Larry or Angela
to see how we can solve
these things we hear about.
So one of the requests is
that you developers told us
you want more flexibility in
issuing refunds to your users.
Currently, on the
server side API,
you can only refund
the latest subscription
order using the purchase token.
You cannot issue a refund
using the order ID,
issue a refund for previous
subscription orders,
or do partial refunds, and
that's really not ideal,
when dealing with subscribers.
LARRY YANG: Well, I have
great news for you, Niko,
and for everyone here.
We've now closed these gaps.
We're extending the
server side API now
to support refunds
using order IDs.
That means now, you can refund
a specific subscription renewal,
not just the latest one.
And starting today, you can
also issue partial refunds.
You can do that on
the Play Console.
You can actually go
over to our sandbox
afterwards and see a
demo of that in action.
And this feature will also be
available on our server side
API next week.
NIKO SCHROER: Cool.
I'm sure that will make a lot
of developers really happy.
Another request
we've heard a lot--
it's maybe the longest
standing feature
request that I personally
know of, is price changes.
At the moment, you cannot
change the price of an SKU once
it's been created.
Obviously, that is very
limiting for businesses,
especially for businesses
whose costs have gone up.
So currently, the only way to
do this is to create a new SKU
and get users to upgrade.
That also means that
you, the developers,
have to do all
the heavy lifting,
like messaging
users or canceling
users who don't upgrade.
LARRY YANG: So
we've heard so much
about this feature from Niko
and other business development
partners that we figured the
easiest way to make them happy
was to just build the feature.
So I'm pleased to announce we
now support mandatory price
changes on existing SKUs.
[APPLAUSE]
All right.
Yeah, see?
NIKO SCHROER: I told you.
LARRY YANG: You made
everyone happy now.
So let's say you need
to roll out a price
change to all of your users.
Maybe your cost of
content has gone up
or the tax structure
has changed in one
of the countries
you do business in.
So now, all you need to do is
you go to the Play Console,
choose the country
or countries where
you need to change the
price, enter the new price,
and click Save, and you're done.
30 days before the
user's renewal date,
we, Play, start sending
emails and push notifications
asking the user to agree
to that price change.
We also give you, the developer,
a seven day head start,
so you can also message
the user in app.
If that renewal date
comes and the user has not
agreed to the price
change, we will take
care of canceling that user.
This feature is currently
in early access.
If you're interested in
trying it out and joining
our early access program,
please visit the link
that you see on the screen here.
NIKO SCHROER: I think it's
so awesome that we finally
let developers do that--
give you that flexibility to
actually grow your business.
I'm sure developers will love
this addition of flexibility
and building their
subscription business
on Play, which actually
brings me to another ask.
I mentioned earlier
how much developers
love the subscription
reports, and that retention
is a key topic.
So what we've heard quite a bit
is that you, developers, ask
for reports that provide
even more details,
especially on the topics on
retention and cancellations.
So Larry, I know we have
a lot to share here.
You want to jump right in?
LARRY YANG: Yep.
So we have a lot of great
news in this area, as well.
So at IO last year, we announced
a brand new subscriptions
dashboard.
A lot of developers have told
us that they love their reports,
and many of our top developers
use those reports every day
to gain insights
onto their business.
But you have all asked for
more capabilities, which
is why we've extended
two new capabilities
in our subscription reports.
Let's take a quick
look at what those are.
First, we're creating
a new retention report.
Now, it's super easy to go in
and look at specific cohorts,
say by SKU or dates
or by country.
Now, you can also drill
into your free trial
conversion and other interesting
metrics in this report.
And you can also
look specifically
at how many renewal periods
various users in the cohorts
have advanced through.
After all, that's the name of
the game when you're running
a subscriptions business.
So the second
change we're making
is we're making improvements
to the cancelation report.
Here's where you will see the
data from the cancellation
survey that Angela and
Niko showed you earlier.
And we'll also give you
details on how your win back
and your retention
features are performing,
such as account hold
and grace period.
All in all, this feature
will be rolling out
over the next few
weeks, and it's
going to help
subscription developers
like you understand and optimize
your entire user lifecycle.
You can get more details on
our new reporting capabilities
in tomorrow's session on
analyzing and benchmarking over
on stage three at
9:30 tomorrow morning.
NIKO SCHROER: OK, I know,
already, I said a lot,
but are you done now?
I think we have more
things to announce.
LARRY YANG: Wait, no,
I've got a few more things
I've just got to squeeze in.
Our engineers have
done so much stuff.
NIKO SCHROER: OK.
LARRY YANG: Just give
me a few more seconds.
NIKO SCHROER: You go.
I sit down in the meantime.
LARRY YANG: I wish
we had more time,
but they told us they're
going to just cut us off
at the end of this session.
So just real quick
here, there's a couple
of other things with the world
I wanted to share with you all.
You all have asked
for the ability
to do quicker renewals on
your test subscriptions,
so we've now rolled
that capability out.
For example, a monthly
test subscription
will now renew in
just five minutes.
You also wanted the ability
to create an intro price
period that's different from
your regular recurrence period.
So we've now rolled out that
capability, so you could say,
for example, offer
$1.00 for 90 days,
and then kick into $10 a
month on your subscription.
And finally, we have
the capability for you
to offer an upgrade, but
keep the user's renewal date
and charge an incremental,
prorated price.
This last feature is only
available with the Play billing
library, which you'll hear a
little bit more about later.
ANGELA YING: All
right, thanks, Larry.
I think my brain
hurts from trying
to remember all those new
features he just covered.
So let's just recap.
We've launched 12 new features
in total, both for users
and for developers.
On the user side, we've created
a better user experience
with the new
subscription center,
including app discovery,
backup payment method,
new deep linking,
and a cancel survey.
For the developer, we're giving
you a ton more flexibility,
including improved
refunds, ability
to change SKU prices,
advanced reporting, and more.
We've bolded the features
that are available now,
so go check them out
as soon as you can.
All of these other
features, we're
working on rolling out in
the next couple of weeks.
So these are the
features that we've
been working on this
past year, but what
are we going to do next year
and the year after that?
Larry, do you want
to tell them more?
LARRY YANG: Yes.
So these features we
just shared are things
you can use right now
to grow your business,
but we're not done.
Our engineers are
hard at work coming up
with new features that will
help you acquire and retain
your subscribers.
So for example, imagine if
your users could sign up
outside of your app,
say, from the Play Store
or from anywhere
else on the web.
Or what if your users
could pay with cash?
Or what if we offered the option
for users to temporarily pause
their subscription, instead
of outright canceling them?
Or maybe we can help
you win back users
by getting them to reactivate
a subscription well
after the subscription
has expired.
NIKO SCHROER: OK, but
wait a sec, Larry.
As exciting as that
sounds, does it
mean that every
single time we launch
one of these new
features, our developers
have to rewrite all of the code?
LARRY YANG: I knew you
were going to ask that,
so we've thought
a lot about this.
So our goal is to
be able to build
all these features in such a way
so that you don't have to do--
you do as little
work as possible.
Our goal is to get as close as
possible to zero integration,
and we want that to happen
on both the client side,
with your app, as well as on
your server side integration.
NIKO SCHROER: That
sounds great, but how
are you going to do that?
LARRY YANG: All
right, just relax.
I got this.
All right, let me just--
give me a few minutes.
I'll talk through how we're
going to make this happen,
all right?
So first, let's
talk about what you
need to do on your client side.
So last fall at Play Time,
we announced version 1.0
of the Play billing library.
The Play billing library
is an abstraction layer
on top of your AIDL file.
API updates are picked
up automatically
when you update your
build dependency file,
and the next time
you compile your app.
So now, there is no more
searching reference code,
sample code, and
copying it and hoping
you got the right
version and all of that.
It's all taken care
of automatically.
Today, we're announcing
version 1.1 of the Play billing
library.
This version
includes the feature
I mentioned earlier where
you can upgrade and keep
the expiration date, and
when we roll out the price
changes, that feature will also
only be available via the Play
billing library.
Using the Play billing
library is very, very simple.
There's just three easy steps.
Now, since no IO presentation
is complete without showing
some code, I'm going to go and
show a few of the code examples
for this.
Now, you're probably
thinking, oh no, we're
near the end of the session.
Now you're going to
show me a bunch of code.
Don't worry.
The whole point of
showing you this code
is to show you just
really how little code
it takes to use the
building library.
So first, all you need to
do is add this one line
to your build.gradle
dependency file.
Second, you need to, of course,
create the billing client
instance.
And to do that,
setup the listener
and connected to Google Play.
Of course, don't forget to build
your own retry policy, in case
your client loses a connection.
And the third and final
step is, of course,
to call the proper method as
you go through your purchase
lifecycle, just
like you do today.
That's it.
NIKO SCHROER: OK, I'm convinced.
It's so straightforward
that even I get it.
And it's actually very
close to zero integration,
but still, it's
late afternoon and I
think we've had enough
slides with code.
At the end of the day,
what really matters
is how developers
actually like it,
and my favorite quote
here comes from Joe Birch.
He's an Android
Eng lead at Buffer,
and he's also a Google
Developer expert
who called the
Google Play billing
library a dream come true.
And we're making this dream
come true for thousands
of developers today, already.
So if you, like me, did
not memorize the code
on those slides,
note down this link
here on this slide
to learn more.
LARRY YANG: So remember, with
the Play billing library,
integration is much, much
simpler-- just a lot less code
to manage.
New features rolling
out in the future
will only be available using
the Play billing library.
Currently, it's only available
for Java and Kotlin developers,
but a C++ version
is coming soon.
OK, so that's what you need
to do on your client side.
Now, here's what you need
to do on your server side.
Earlier, we talked about real
time developer notifications.
Let me go through a little
bit of detail on what it is
and how you can use
it today, and then
how it will prepare
you for the future.
So with real time
developer notifications,
you set up a Google Cloud
Pub/Sub integration,
and we send you
real time messages
whenever important events happen
with your users' subscription.
So for example, when you
have a new user that signs up
or an existing user that renews,
we'll send you a message,
and you now know
you need to continue
or you need to grant
a new entitlement
or continue to grant an
entitlement to that user.
If today, you've integrated
and implemented account hold--
and by the way, in case you
weren't looking in that video,
you really, really should
integrate with account hold.
We now send you a real
time developer notification
when the user has a payment
issue and goes on hold
or when the user recovers
from their payment issue
and they come off hold.
So now, immediately,
you will know
when to withhold entitlement
or to grant back entitlement
to that user.
This is super important
if you have a service that
operates cross-platform.
Say you have users who
sign up on Android,
but might consume on Web
or other mobile platforms.
Real time developer
notifications
also tell you about
voluntary cancellation, where
the user chooses to cancel.
In this situation, when
you get that message,
right away, you should start
trying to win back that user.
Maybe remind the user about some
new content that's coming up
or tell them about some features
that you notice that they
haven't used in your app.
And using the deep link that
Angela told you about earlier,
you then drive the user back
to the subscription center,
where they click on
the Restore button.
And with one tap, they become
an active subscriber again.
So these are some
of the things you
can do today, right now,
with real time developer
notifications.
But in the future,
if you integrate now,
you'll be ready for
some of the new things
that we'll be rolling out.
Like say a user temporarily
pauses their subscription.
We'll send you a
developer notification
so you'll know that's happened.
Or if we got a user to
reactivate their subscription
after it's expired, you'll
get a real time developer
notification, and you now know
to grant entitlement back.
But remember, with real time
developer notifications,
the notification's only
telling you that a subscription
state has changed.
You still need to call
our server side API
and query the full state
of the subscription,
and know exactly
what you need to do--
exactly what action you need
to take with that subscriber.
NIKO SCHROER: So as
I mentioned earlier,
real time developer
notification has
become an essential part of
our top developer subscription
setup.
Check out the details on how
to set up real time developer
notifications on
this link, which
takes you to the developer
pages and has all the details.
LARRY YANG: So
remember, if you want
to future proof
your integration,
be sure to use both the Play
billing library on your client
side, and integrate with real
time developer notifications
on the server side.
All right.
Phew.
That was a lot of stuff.
So give us a couple
of minutes here
and we're just going
to, real quick,
recap all the stuff that we
introduced and told you about.
NIKO SCHROER: So we
started off with talking
about how much you guys
love subscriptions,
thanks to the great
work you have done.
Thanks to the great products
and subscription services
you have launched
and you're operating.
ANGELA YING: We've shared with
you 12 new features, including
many features built around
the new subscription center.
LARRY YANG: And
finally, we talked
about how you can use
the Play billing library
and integrate with real
time developer notifications
so that you're ready as
we roll out new features.
NIKO SCHROER: Yeah,
and because obviously,
this is only day one of IO, so
there are more great sessions
that you should
definitely check out.
Two we want to recommend to
you are the 6:00 PM session
on games today,
which will also talk
about subscriptions and games.
And then tomorrow at 9:30,
you can learn much more
about all the great reports
we only touched on today.
ANGELA YING: You
can also check out
demos of a lot of
the features we've
announced in the sandbox,
which is over there.
And we also have an
office hour specifically
for Google Play subscriptions
tomorrow at 2:30 PM.
LARRY YANG: If you
have more questions,
join us over at the Android and
Play conversations area right
after this session.
I think it's just on the
other side of the wooden deck
to your right, as you walk out.
And lastly, we would love
to get your feedback.
After all, how is Niko going
to get better at his jokes
if we don't give him feedback?
OK.
That's it, everyone.
Thank you very much, and
enjoy the rest of your IO.
NIKO SCHROER: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]